Können wir ewig leben und sind wir gar nicht tot wenn wir tot sind
Doch wie fühlte sich eigentlich an zu sterben wann genau ist man tot und was kommt danach ihr habt euch
Genau das bei whatsapp gewünscht wie ihr meine nummer whatsapp hätten könnte dass er vater
Am ende des videos und bekommt jetzt alle facts zu diesem thema und alle details zum tod
herzlich willkommen bei diesem tödlichen klicks um science-fiction video
Ja für viele gilt der amerikanische soft
Ihre lose als ein medizinisches wunder
2009 brach er zusammen sein herz stand still und sein gehirn arbeitete nicht mehr tirano sie war tot in einem der besten krankenhäuser
nordamerikas aber gaben ärzte teams alles sie shoppen sein herz mit
360 0 verpasst neben eine herzdruckmassage und das immer wieder zehn minuten später zeigte tirano sie
Immer noch keine lebenszeichen doch die ärztinnen und ärzten machen weiter dabei lag hier eine grenze an der einige andere teams die behandlung
wahrscheinlich schon abgebrochen hätten tirano sie bekamen adrenalin gespritzt doch auch nach 30 minuten zeigte er keine reaktion
sollte das also doch alles umsonst gewesen sein
40 minuten war der chauffeur jetzt schon tot die meisten ärzte teams hätten wohl jetzt spätestens
Abgebrochen denn das risiko ist groß dass weite teile des gehirns abgestorben sind die frage ist nämlich ob man es wirklich schafft mit der beatmung
Genug sauerstoff ins gehirn zu bekommen selbst wenn das herz wieder zuschlagen beginnen würde könnten die folgen fatal sei nach
47 minuten und 20 sekunden
Pcs laut die null linie auf dem monitor geht über in einen starken ausschlag nach oben und ja
Der fall hat tatsächlich ein happy end und was für eins der alu sie
Konnte das krankenhaus nach drei wochen verlassen zu fuß und genau genommen ist der kein medizinisches wunder dafür aber ein
spektakulärer erfolg der modernen reanimation medizin bis zu 30 prozent des üblichen sauerstoffs kann das gehirn durch eine gut
ausgeführte liebt wiederbelebung erhalten und das reicht nur das problem
Das ist super anstrengend selbst profis können dieses niveau nicht länger als ein paar minuten durchhalten aber aus meinem bekanntenkreis
Da kenne ich einen fall, wo eine ältere frau mehrmals immer wieder nur durch
herzdruckmassage und durch beatmung 30 minuten
Am leben gehalten wurde und der körper
Mit sauerstoff versorgt werden konnte so dass die personen danach wieder reanimiert werden konnte und diese beatmung und
Herzdruckmassage hat eine zierliche frau gemacht. Also es geht aber
Herz lungen maschinen brustgurt und hydraulische pumpen können das viel besser außerdem enorm wichtig kälte die den körper des verstorbenen
herunterkühlt diagnose ist leben jedenfalls haben zum einen die ausdauer der
Notfallmediziner und zum anderen die kälte gerettet was der fall von der musik deutlich zeigt ist noch nicht
allzu lange bekannt der tod ist ein prozess und eben kein moment er tritt langsam ein und
Breitet sich im körper aussetzt stunden danach kann er noch unterbrochen werden unter bestimmten bedingungen natürlich noch vor 60 jahren dachte
Man anders bum bum bum und ende so lange eben wie das herz schlägt leben wir wenn es
Aufhört sind wir tot und das ist dann auch nicht mehr rückgängig zu machen der österreichisch amerikanische arzt peter seiffert damals das buch abc
Situation indem er erstmalig beschrieben hat wie man einen menschen nach einem herzstillstand wiederbeleben kann durch beatmen
freihalten der atemwege und herzdruckmassage
doch was genau lässt uns nach 80 90 100 jahre mittlerweile manchmal sogar 120 jahren auf
Natürliche art und weise sterben da kann man nämlich dann nicht viel tun in unserem körper
sind millionen von zellen und diese altern bisher daran sterben unsere innere uhr tickt denn irgendwann stoppt ein wichtiger biologischer
prozesse in unserem körper die
alltägliche zellteilung die dafür sorgt dass alte zellen
Ausgetauscht werden und ersetzt werden die alten zellen sterben ab und leben nur noch in einer art stand by modus der körperliche verfall
Im alter beruht aber auch noch auf anderen mechanismen
Am ende fallen dann mehrere organe und biologische prozesse aus die lunge das gehirn oder das
herz-kreislauf-system werden manchmal auch als
Eintrittspforten des todes bezeichnet medizinisch gesehen gibt es auch nicht den tod zum einen gibt es den so genannten klinischen tod
Wenn das herz kreislaufsystem stockt und organe nicht mehr versorgt werden manchmal kamen dem noch mit beatmungsmaschine neben oder einer herzdruckmassage
entgegengewirkt werden beim
irreversiblen hirntod sieht das ganz anders aus laut der
definition in deutschland bedeutet das den ausfall des groß und klein hirns und des hirnstamms
das bewusstsein geht damit verloren und zwar unumkehrbar übrigens können selbst in diesem zustand noch in sehr tiefen schichten
mancher hirnregionen gehirnzellen aktiv seien maschinen können manche funktionen eines hirntoten körpers in gang hält
er kann seine eigene körpertemperatur
regulieren und manche hirntote frauen haben sogar noch ihr baby bis zur geburt ausgetragen in
operationen reagieren manche hirntoten patienten auf reize der blutdruck steigt an und muskeln bewegen sich
medizinisch gesehen sind dafür reflexe des rückenmarks verantwortlich und nicht das empfinden von schmerzen
Um die diagnose des hirn todes
Zu stellen gibt es ganz klare richtlinien die zwei ärzte unabhängig voneinander durch zu gehen haben ihr habt sich ja auch schon mal von
nahtoderfahrungen gehört das netzwerk nahtod erfahrung schätzt dass etwa vier millionen menschen in deutschland schon mal so ein
Mysteriöses erlebnis hinter sich gebracht haben beispielsweise nach einem unfall in den berichten heißt es dann
so etwas wie
Es fühlt sich einfach an wie ein perfekter schlaf aber ohne träume andere berichten davon dass sie es eher wie ein leben nach dem tod
empfunden haben beispielsweise von anderlecht vision
Am ende des tunnels oder als eine art lebens film manchmal
Sind es schöne gefühle aber oft spielen auch angst und panik eine rolle medizinisch gesehen treten solche
nahtoderfahrungen zwischen dem klinischen tod und der reanimation auf studien zufolge
berichten etwa ein viertel der patientinnen und patienten die einen klinischen tod durchgemacht haben von, nahtoderfahrungen
häufig vor allem wenn die reanimation lange gedauert hat oder
besonders schwer war neurologisch gesehen ist der nato quasi ein ausdruck einer funktion stören gehirn wenn eben die versorgung über längere zeit nicht gut war
der bereich der rechtsmedizin der weiß detailliert über die verschiedenen phasen des todes bescheid fest steht dass die organe oft noch eine zeit ohne
sauerstoff und nährstoffe klarkommen die zellen
Im gehirn sterben nach etwa fünf minuten das herz hält bis zu 30 minuten aus dann sterben auch die
Zellen in leber und lunge das blut sinkt ab weil es nicht mehr
Zu gold todes flecken entstehen und das kennt er aus krimis die piraten ziemlich viel zum beispiel über die
todesursache und den zeitpunkt ähnlich wie die totenstarre die nach etwa zwei stunden
einsetzt konkret versteifen sich die muskeln und sterben ab nach einigen tagen
Löst sich die starre wieder ein bis zwei tage nach dem einsetzen des todes gibt dann auch der magen darm trakt auf
bakterien beginnen mit der zersetzung des körpers noch länger halten spermien durch und zwar bis zu drei tage lang
30 jahre lang dauert der komplette
zersetzungsprozess, des menschlichen körpers danach ist wirklich nichts mehr von uns übrig wie genau sich die momente des sterbens anfühlen das wiederum
Ist noch weitgehend unerforscht wie sollte das auch gehen schließlich ist noch keiner der mir bekannten toten wieder auferstanden doch es gibt
tierversuche dazu demnach versiegt die
gehirnaktivität während des sterbeprozess nicht allmählich sondern steigt noch einmal für kurze zeit deutlich an
das hat beispielsweise ein forschungsteam der university of michigan
2013 berichtet bisher ging man allerdings davon aus dass es diesen vorgang beim menschen nicht gibt gibt es aber nach neuesten erkenntnissen und
vielleicht ist er für die beschriebenen
nahtoderfahrung verantwortlich jedenfalls durch diesen irrtum ist als phänomen beim menschen noch gänzlich
unerforscht wie sieht das sterben in zukunft ausschließlich tüfteln forschungsteams weltweit daran uns ewiges leben zu verschaffen und ja
Die visionen der wissenschaft sind gigantisch die mit ursela stiftung in virginia will es in zukunft schaffen dass menschen
biologisch gesehen für immer bei einem alter von 25 jahren bleiben können 90-jährige sollen
So gesund bleiben die 40 jahre jüngere die biotechnologie
macht immer mehr fortschritte in richtung ewiges leben unterstützt durch viel geld der pharmaindustrie das time magazin hatte
2013 gefragt kann google soll des kann google den tod aufhalten vorher hatte der digital konzern google nämlich seine tochter
kaliko
gegründet
Um mit 1,5 milliarden dollar eine antwort auf genau diese frage zu finden
die hälfte der finanzierung hatte ein pharmaunternehmen dazu steuert auch der
silicon valley milliardär larry ellison ist ein todes gegner und hofft dass viel geld zu
zahlreichen wissenschaftlichen entdeckung führt die dann in kombination mit besseren
heilmethoden unser leben verlängern können bis das zur realität wird
kann aber auch jeder einzelne selbst dafür sorgen die qualität seines eigenen lebens zu verbessern denn
im besten fall erhöht dies auch die lebensdauer forschungsteams weltweit verweisen immer wieder darauf dass
meditation zb stress reduzieren kann und viel stress beschleunigt die
biologische alterung das sagen
Viele studien natürlich und sport gesunde ernährung und so weiter und so fort und wenn das dann trotzdem nicht reicht auch
im bereich der notfallmedizin
Sind forschungsteams weltweit optimistisch man geht davon aus dass wir in 20 jahren etwa in der lage sein werden menschen zu rennen
Reanimieren die bereits seit 24 stunden tot sind ein fall wie die alu sie wäre dann nicht mehr die ausnahme sondern die regel
was aber passiert
Nach dem tod gibt es ein leben danach werden wir wieder geboren was passiert mit der menschlichen seele ist sie unsterblich ihr wisst alle
Was die verschiedenen religionen dazu meinen manchmal werden als beweis dafür die nahtoderfahrung
Benutzt der körper habe sich von der seele gelöst oder die seele vom körper und an der schwelle zum jenseits gestanden darüber gibt es
wissenschaftlich gesehen aber absolut keinen konsens es gibt durchaus auch wissenschaftler wissenschaftlerin die an solche szenarien glauben die meisten
expertinnen in diesem bereich aber erklären
Nahtoderfahrung neurologisch und so liefern diese erlebnisse keinerlei hinweise auf ein leben nach dem tod oft wird auch die
quantenphysik bei dieser diskussion ins spiel gebracht
kann
Sie die verbindung zwischen dem physikalischen körper und der der immateriellen seele schaffen oder
Zerschlägt sie diese sogar letztendlich ist die quantenphysik allerdings auch nur eine theorie über das verhalten
physikalischer teilchen meiner meinung nach ist es zweifelhaft dass sie seriöse aussagen über eine immaterielle seele
treffen kann klingt eher nach
Ziemlichen quatsch ja und so bleibt es weiter eine
glaubensfrage ob es eine unsterbliche seele gibt oder eben nicht die wissenschaft jedenfalls kann diese frage nicht
Beantworten wenn er als erstes neues zu diesem thema und zu allen anderen themen erfahren wollt dann endet meine
telefonnummer bei whatsapp dann erfahrt ihr von mir vor allen anderen vom neuesten video
garantiert ihr könnt dort direkt über mich in der redaktion von blick zum mitmachen und mehr zum beispiel themen vorschlagen oder an
abstimmungen teilnehmen und somit bestimmen was hier bei pixum passiert der direkte draht zu mir einfach hier draufklicken
und natürlich nicht das aber mit der
Genau locker vergessen und hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch. Draufklicken ewiges leben möglich ansonsten bis dann
bleibt dran